hi I'm Mike I'm a lecturer at the
University of Surrey and in my talk I'm
going to show how we use the wool from
private cloud to do all our student
assessments
hello everybody this is actually my
fourth time to take conference and I
remember when I came here in 2014 this
was a year the the cloud was released
and since we used automated grading for
our exams in Zurich I thought let's try
to get this to the cloud and make it
available for everyone on the web yeah
and it took yeah more than three years
to actually make it happen
but fortunately now we got it and while
I was flying into Chicago in Zurich a
hundred fifty students took a test
live in class and everything was graded
and everything was hosted using the
private cloud and graded with a cloud so
I did not have to do anything and today
I'm going to show you how this looks
like and also how do we create the
questions so what you see here is is our
LMS code SILVER this is completely like
backed up by the Wolfram cloud so we
have got apps for all the educational
purposes and we feed all the content
from Mathematica so I'm just prepared
this this course for today and since I
want to focus on assessment I'm just
showing you this for four second so
this all comes from a mathematical
notebook but this is on the web there's
a web browser and we do have all kinds
of interactive elements videos and here
are some manipulate or in this case it's
a dynamic module this is a cloud object
so this completely lives in a cloud you
don't need Mathematica to run this as a
student currently our cloud is hosted in
Germany so that's why it takes a few
seconds but it really works so yeah you
can imagine how many yeah cool and
interactive things you can do having the
ability to just put all the manipulates
and dynamic content on a web page okay
and assume this is our lecture or the
course you're attending and at the end
you might want to test your knowledge
and you can see here it's switch to our
assessment app and what you see here now
is a self-test and now I'm going through
the questions and afterwards I will show
you how we created those questions and
how they are graded okay so even though
this does not look like a forum page or
what you might be used to in terms of
the the Wolfram labeling and so on but
all these questions are cloud objects so
this yeah okay
so I'm just filling in the questions and
later on I I will explain them in a
little bit more detail so this is um
yeah very simplified questions as all
the others just to show you the
principles and like the features we can
already cover so I'm going to fill this
with a four let's see how this is going
to be great it the next question is a
question that involves several different
plots and it's asking me to find the one
with a seven extrema so let me just log
in this now and yeah by the way so
obviously when you're in a classroom
with 150 students you need to make sure
that everyone submits the the question
to his like account and so not only that
each question is a cloud object so also
each student has a different set of
questions so we end up with a lot of
cloud objects in this and all the
answers are stored there as well and I'm
just going to the next question which is
finding a number which is not an integer
between 2 and 13 I'm just going to fill
this here you might get an idea of 4
question like this they're more than
just one correct solution and I'm going
to show you how do this in this question
we use the knowledge space through 4
from language and in this case we're
asking for city
within a distance of 300 miles to London
but outside the UK so it's not a very
like terribly hard question to answer
but imagine you wanted to try to grade
this automatically you would need to
like yeah set up or define a set of
cities and yeah okay so in this case I'm
trying amsterdam here oh right
I reset it so maybe someone else someone
has an idea a city within 300 miles to
London but outside the UK Paris okay
check Paris okay the next one
oh I expected
alright so the next one is a question go
to the park and take a picture of a
squirrel and upload the picture here
since this is a web browser you could
use your iPhone or tablet to do this
test and yeah it's it's not what we use
in higher education but you can imagine
there was an elementary school and you
go to the zoo and instead of just
letting the the kids walk around you can
give them some some questions or tasks
to do okay so I'm not going to park now
I'm cheating a little bit so I'm just
taking any image from Google should we
try this or maybe this what do you like
you can try this okay so I'm just saving
it now to my desktop from a mobile
device I could use the camera and
Oh unfortunately that's a PNG and to
look for JPEG
this is a check okay
so I'm answering this question now with
an image I submitted
takes a few seconds and it's logged in
so the the last question type is also
really powerful so we thought like
manipulator are really useful for
teaching and demonstrating and they are
really good to get an intuition but we
wanted to use them within an assessment
so we want to ask a question and just
let the answer be whatever you do within
the dynamic object so in this case it's
asking for local minimum and so it will
be somewhere here so you know and I
submitted okay so and now all set so now
I want to see the results of this and
now the grading happens or within the
Wolfram cloud so it will take a couple
of seconds and now it switches to the
next app and this app immediately shows
the results how I did in this self-test
okay so it turns out I got five out of
six correct so that means the last one
like the image of the scroll that was
accepted and yeah unfortunately the
first one I did not correct
so my answer was four but yeah it's
three so we also give a feedback or at
least
a little explanation so that students
understand what's going on okay so this
this is the assessment and now I'm going
to show you how we are creating those so
leaving the browser now and opening
Mathematica and
so what you see now is creo
that's an authoring tool we developed we
delivered as a pallet so you can think
of this as an add-on to Mathematica you
can log into this all the files will be
stored in a cloud so that's very
convenient for collaborating with
several people teaching assistants so
ever and now I'm going to open so it's
fetching all the projects I'm working on
at the moment and what I showed you
today was the the test the demo
questions and this is how the tool looks
[Music]
so let's look at the questions so that
the first one the plain and Static one
what is 1 plus 2 and that's that's
really trivial and kind of boring so
that's what yeah most tools might might
be capable of and the way to grade it
would just be to say you're given and
must be equal 3 ok so how do we inject
individualization and randomization so
whenever we have something like a
multiple choice all the alternatives you
can see here randomized so that is to
prevent cheating when you're in a large
classroom so it should not be too easy
to copy answers from your neighbor what
is really powerful and the reason we
you use Mathematica to do it is that we
can just inject a parameter into this
question so instead of which plot shows
five extrema I introduce a parameter
here extrema and I say this parameter
goes from three to seven and I can use
this parameter within anything like
plots and yeah texts and tables or
whatever expression you want to put and
yet so this is this is how I created the
alternatives and you can always see a
preview here so this is creating the the
cloud object now so this is how it would
look like I can I can test grading but
just to show you this is this is
randomized and individualized so now the
the five change to a four and even if it
was a 5 then the order of the
alternatives will be different ok so now
in many cases you have multiple correct
solutions and often it will be like the
the question or to ask more realistic
question you have to make them a little
bit more open so you in the real world
is usually not just one correct solution
to a question and this is the same
principle so in this case we are looking
for a number between x and y it's just
putting in some some numbers when the
actual question for student is created
and the way to grade it is we look at
the interval between x and y make sure
that the answer is
the number entered is within this
interval and as a second condition we
say it should not be an integer and so
this is our grading for this question
and again so I can always preview this
and put in some number and I can test it
here so it doesn't look too pretty yet
but so this this was correct here okay
now I'm going to show you the more
interesting questions so this was the
the question with ik City and so here we
use geo distance so whatever city your
answer here
it would calculate the geo distance from
London to the city you entered it would
decide like is it less than the actual
distance given by this parameter three
to 500 miles and as a second condition
we said it should not be within the UK
and so we don't need to give a set of
all the maybe hundreds of cities within
this area we can just use knowledge
built into Wolfram language and the
scroll question so this is really I
think is really amazing like how easy it
is to or to set up a question like this
remember so what what this does is it's
automatically grading an image you put
in there so it's detecting what is
you can see on the image and it's
writing this and and all you need to do
for this is saying like is this an image
instance of squirrel that's it it's that
easy so the the last type which we are
using a lot the interactive response
this worked like this so you have your
plot you say there's a locator you make
it dynamic and what you extract from
this answer is a variable in this case
it's X and here in the grading you would
say is X the given answer member of a of
a certain region and maybe you can
imagine it's not so easy to point to the
exact point to the exact minimum so we
put a disc here so this is like our
tolerance so if you're within the green
area with the locator so you're fine
with when you're without outside it will
be marked as incorrect okay so that's
basically what we have now as you can
see we only use three question types and
when you see other tools you end up with
lots of question types and the good
thing is we can keep things like pretty
open just using free response and by
setting a response type which is
actually just an interpreter we can
accept pretty much anything like a city
and number string correct
but we could also grade mathematic and
notebooks and Excel files so that's
pretty powerful and I think the nice
thing is that that we can make it really
convenient for students and teachers to
to use it on the web but also may take
full advantage of all the features from
from the Wolfram language so yeah any
questions so we were testing it or in
two courses at the moment and we are
studying couple more projects soon so we
are not selling it right now but we are
open for some early adapters so
especially when you are proficient in
Mathematica so we could give you an
account and you can create your own
course materials and assessments and use
our platform
yeah so I mean that's that's that's the
idea then we can make it available for
others and I can I can show you the
insides from this is large cause we are
holding now so here you can see all the
students all the course materials for
this course here we have assessments and
the grading so this was the Chris we
took this heat this week and here you
see the results it was only five
questions so you have this distribution
but yeah so it works so I was a little
bit nervous because of the the cloud and
there I mean this this test involved
thousands of cloud objects and yeah but
it really works
yeah
now it's um it's actually we have three
answer types so free response and some
selection multiple choice and the the
interactive response where you move a
slider or something like this and it's
it's it's pretty like open so you can
whatever manipulate our dynamic module
you create in Wolfram language you can
pull it there so it can be drag-and-drop
it can be yeah a slider or so we we have
we hope that we can keep it at flexible
because yeah so I personally I've seen
quite some tools in the in the last
years and then yeah they might be
sophisticated but then you end up with
20 or 30 question types and you need
like half a year to really understand
what the difference so at the moment
it's it's you still need a significant
knowledge of Wolfram language but yeah
yeah
what we what we should do is give some
examples of course so that the users can
adapt it easily but we are not planning
to to make this like yeah just that you
have five templates and you can only
choose to enter some numbers so it will
be it will be open yeah and again
so we handle all this in a cloud so all
the assessments of the self tests exams
assignments they are created on demand
so there's no way of someone getting the
questions before the assignment are
started we can great like instantly we
can grade at a certain schedule and so
that's that's a pretty flexible and
useful approach so you can you can
inject your assessments within your
lectures you can do all kinds of
homework we already did presentations
this semester and also the the final
exams at the end so this is a fully
integrated system ok so thanks for
attention
[Applause]